this comment is such a good example of the Dunning Kruger effect
if you don't know what that is
let me explain
The Dunning Kruger effect is a cognitive bias
where people with very little knowledge or expertise in a particular area
are much more likely to be confident
and overestimate their abilities in that area
basically being uninformed leads to over confidence
and then as you acquire knowledge on the subject
you are more likely to become less confident
because you start to realize how much there is to know about that subject
and you start to realize how much you don't know
so here I was
talking about a very persuasive book on misogyny by Professor Kate Manne
when this commenter commented to tell me that it was “nonsense”
I commented back and said
you should read the book and then come back and tell me if it changed your mind
they confidently responded that they refuse to engage with books on this subject
and that the solution is somewhere else
I talk about feminism and the law on my page
so the Dunning Kruger effect is always in my comments
but um
I wanna hear from you like what
do you have an expertise in something
or does this happen a lot on your page too
what are you talking about
tell me where you see this happening